The paints are mixed with fluid from animals' gallbladders...
...in order not to break up in the water.
Then, they wait to be turned into tulips, roses and carnations...
...at the artisan's hands.
Gum is harvested from the tragacanth plant,...
...which is collected from the mountains of Anatolia.
This gum is used to give the liquid its consistency...
...and make it possible to carry paint around.
The Ebru artist takes up a brush made from rose branches and horse hair...
...and goes to the tray.
After a while, maybe a Gelgit style will begin, maybe a Bulbul Yuvasi style,...
...maybe a Sal shape, maybe a combed shape,...
...maybe a Hatip style floral design, maybe a floral shape.
The comb and the hand of the artist gracefully thins the paint with oil...
...and imprints a picture on the page,...
...leaving a sense of inner joy not visible to the naked eye.
Once an Ebru artist feels that joy, she never leaves her tray again.
She spends her years watching the magical dance of the colors in the water.